history to me is not necessarily about
remembering
the dates it's more about experiencing
that history
while i'm learning the language hi there
steve kaufman here again
uh talking about languages of course and
today i'm going to talk about languages
and history
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
if you follow me on spotify
or at least any other
podcast service please leave review
why history why do i want to talk about
history because history fascinates me
and i think you know i realize that
people watch my videos either because
they're working on improving their
english
or because they find them you know my
videos in some way
motivating and encouraging
and therefore encourages them
to continue learning languages which
in turn motivates me to make more videos
and so i was thinking the other day you
know what motivates me to learn
languages so it started with a professor
as i've said before that i had at mcgill
university because we had french at
school i wasn't very interested uh there
were you know in a city of three million
people in those days in montreal
there were two million french speakers
and one million english speakers i could
have gone out and found people to talk
to if i wanted to
i wasn't very motivated
until this professor
we had this course french civilization
and we had this tremendous book and you
know between uh you know moliere and
hassine and the voltaire and and reading
all these uh
bits and pieces of what some of the
thinkers montagne and others or even
seeing
uh you know the
famous painters like david and watto and
all of this
it for whatever reason it turned my
crank and it was the professor but it
was largely a matter of history i
suddenly became conscious
of this this french civilization
which like all civilizations went back
in history but i became interested
specifically in french civilization not
that it is
any more fascinating or
more valuable than any other
civilization but it has its
charm its works of art its
its architecture its literature its
history
and i can still remember when i first
arrived in paris when i had hitchhiked
across
the ocean
on a on a small german [ __ ] steamer and
hitchhiked into paris and i saw the
actor triumph and i said i was just
beside myself because this is this
history that i had become so
uh you know interested in
and so that was french
and then i went to france and i studied
for three years and then the next
language was chinese and i can remember
when i got into chinese what fascinated
me again was history
i remember
of course when we first start out we
have to read things that are relatively
uninteresting and i've mentioned that we
have to
deal with relatively uninteresting
content uh with a lot of repetition but
once we're able to start clawing our way
out of that and we go after things of
interest to me it's history that i go
after and so with chinese struck me so
romantic the idea that this ancient
civilization of china had all of a
sudden sort of come into contact
with the west with different ways of
thinking with science with different
political systems and how did they cope
with that and so for me
some of the literature and the history
of the
sort of first half of the 20th century
in china was was absolutely fascinating
and i devoured material on that subject
unfortunately in chinese to read about
ancient history very often the material
is more in sort of literary chinese
and there is just a limitless limitless
number of names to remember
and i found that well you know it was
fascinating to conjure up the hung the
tang dynasty and how they lived and so
forth or other dynasties the han
and the chiang but the portion of
history that fascinated me was the early
part of the 20th century so that was
chinese when i came to japan i've
mentioned before i listened over and
over to the history of the showa era
which was produced by nhk
which had the real voices of the real
people in radio programs and elsewhere
or radio announcers describing events
during the showa era which began and
again i forget you know i love history
but i forget it as fast as i learned it
but was it sometime in the 20s up until
the second world war and then after the
second world war
um yeah the showa era that went i say i
can't remember it doesn't matter history
to me is not necessarily about
remembering
the dates it's more about experiencing
that history
while i'm learning the language so
through the language i'm getting a
flavor of the country which then
influences my perspective on the country
so that was true of uh of japanese
and i can recollect recollect listening
to history history of poland as soon as
i got through the mini stories i found
on
publio.pl i think it is
um a book where
i could get both the audiobook and the
ebook and so i could read it on link and
i could listen to it history of poland
history of ukraine history of russia
uh even certain novels like
every italian person i've ever met say
it tells me that they find
promesi sposie by mazzoni very boring
because they have to read it in school
but for me it conjures up
17th century i believe it is
you know northern italy and and so again
it's history and to me it's just
i remember jogging uh listening to it
prometheus posey and i listened to a lot
of it wonderful uh rendition by uh
naratore which is a great site for
people who are learning italian
i mean every language when i was looking
and
greek the same way i found a podcast
where they talked about how the the uh
parthenon was built
stoned by stone and that was very
difficult for me because i didn't have
the words but at least was interesting
and so i and and even now you know it's
it's so fascinating like i i stopped
listening to or at least learning korean
because there was a lack of content at
my level
but
it's sort of interesting there was
interesting content was too difficult
there was
content that i could understand it was
not interesting
uh but lo and behold my wife has started
watching these historical dramas korean
historical dramas and so that just gets
me keen again so there's this one called
the the crowned clown which is like most
of these historical dramas not very
believable
but still fascinating and of course it
presents the costumes and and in that
it's it's it's that period when
the manchus
who are described there as being the
late jinn because the jin dynasty
invaded
the song
chinese dynasty back in the
i guess the 12th century
and this is the same meant to people
uh and they're once again go invade
china and they invade korea
and they then become they start calling
themselves the manchu and they call
themselves the ching
dynasty but the interesting thing there
again is so i look up on on wikipedia
and you see pictures of the sort of
uh noorhasi or
however he's pronounced who is thinking
you know the leader of
jin later jin eventually
which are known in english as the chen
or anyway
so he dresses like it's all chinese
culturally chinese and yet the
sort of scrolls behind him are written
in this
vertical script
that when i look it up
it's
the
mongol
manchu script which is an adaptation of
the uyghur script which is in turn an
adaptation of the sagdian script the
saudians are are an iranian-speaking
people who control the silk road uh
and that in turn
has its origins in the middle east uh
you know aramaic or i don't know syriac
or
phoenician it's all connected and what
you begin what you start to realize
after a while is all history is
connected
so
we tend to think of you know the major
countries in the world they did all
history plus our own country but of
course you know the manchus had their
history the mongols have their history
uh they connect through central asia
to
central asia which a thousand years ago
was a major center of of world culture
uh connecting the arab world with the
you know indian world with the persian
world with the chinese world
uh
persians had a major influence as in
arabs in
the tang dynasty there were many persian
and arab traders and and
literary people and artists in uh i
guess it was hangzhou i can't remember
so all of this stuff is connected
so when i learned persian now of course
i i'm just loving because a lot of the
historical stuff is too difficult
but again
sahara has created these 26 episodes of
iranian history in easier language for
me and so i listen to that and read that
and and that course you know stimulates
me to go off and read about
uh the history of persia elsewhere so i
just want to
pass that along i mean i could go on i'm
trying to think of other language like
ukrainian again
to understand ukraine you have to read
ukrainian history and you have to read
ukrainian history written by ukrainians
so if you're going to do that then may
as well read it in ukrainian and may as
well listen to the audiobook in
ukrainian which i have done and so that
gives you a perspective on ukraine which
is different
from
a perspective on ukrainian history
written by
someone from poland because they
dominated ukraine free for
hundreds of years or written by someone
from russia russia also dominated
portions of ukraine for many years
and so when you get the history of the
people
spoken by the people in their language
and you can access it and their history
and their culture and their
you know various
cultural creations throughout their
history that's what
motivates me to learn the language it's
not simply the fact that i might be able
to speak to someone of course i want to
speak to someone but the motivation for
me in these languages
uh is is
largely history
and
watching that
netflix video the other day has gotten
me motivated again
to go and brush up my korean we'll see
what happens all these competing
uh you know attractive languages to
learn anyway i just wanted to share that
with you uh thank you for listening
and remember
to get to achieve your goals in language
learning you have to be motivated you
have to find things that motivate you
and you have to
read and listen on those subjects of
interest and i'll leave a few videos
that relate to that thanks for listening
bye for now